we are indeed with alice lee after an
incredible victory with the white pieces
against uh the streaky tatev abrahamian
first of all congratulations alice
that's a big victory for you how did you
approach uh this match do you know
tatevoid
um yeah um thank you so um yeah i mean i
think that her general playing style is
to like kind of attack and that's what
she did this game
um so it was kind of dangerous for me
so the opening i played usually is like
yeah like with knight f3 then e3
it
doesn't usually allow attacks but she
managed to like create something with
bishop takes h3
um so i think that was basically my
general approach to this game were you
surprised by her time spencer
especially after that rook to d5 and
then spending another five minutes on to
g5 and you were playing so fast how
would you feel at that point yeah i mean
um i thought that i could defend with
like kunichiwan and bishop f1 so i
didn't think her attack was that great
which is why i kind of blitzed out a few
moves not really blitzed but
um i think her time management probably
could have improved um but like
it's kind of hard to play when you're
trying to think about how to create an
attack um and
she tried
and when did you feel like you're
pretty much taking over and securing
that full point
um i wasn't exactly sure
well she played the attack i mean i
thought that i could probably defend
so
yeah
i thought that here yeah i was winning
because yeah queen takes f2 rook d2 and
then um
another
of her problem is that she has some
background problems um
so like knight takes e4 as possible i
thought the knight d5 would also be okay
but
yeah after knight h5
knight f4 i think i should be winning um
i felt that i was better after like i
was able to do rook i see one one move
before she did the bishop sacrifice but
um i didn't think it was like that
easily winning
yeah um around here
rook i see one um because my rooks
control the open files and her work on
g6 is a bit misplaced if she's like not
going to go for the attack
nicely placed rooks you're saying the
rook is off side on you if the attack
doesn't work the rook on g6 is just off
sights you're saying yeah
uh very impressive you held your nerve
uh in the face of a very uh fierce
attacker
congratulations and uh much success for
the remaining game tomorrow thank you
this is very often but a cold-blooded 12
year old just taking a piece defending
like it was absolutely no issue
whatsoever right and she wins a huge
game here against tatif on the verge of
qualifying to the finals of the
championship bracket is alice the only
need to draw tomorrow tatif with her
back against the wall and